[Music]
all right y'all
we'll start with the photo
you already know though
wait is that a taco
roast no pretty cool dude it's happening
dude that's a massive roach it's a
cockroach it's a good girl from pigeons
is it a real cockroach
it is a real cockroach is it controlled
by a computer it is controlled by a
computer
dude so it's like a cyborg it is like a
sideboard oh but so it's a live
cockroach but now they're controlling it
they are controlling whoa
so it's like a remote concocta roach
uh yes patent pending very nice job very
natural remote
real quick everybody can see this video
check it out
that's tight we'll fast forward a little
bit because we're getting bored during
some of it okay okay in singapore a
group of uh [ __ ] scientist uh cyborg
insects one day crawl earth
what
oh that's tight let's get out of the bio
stuff all right check this out so
oh look look at this right here this is
crazy
emulate all the muscles individually
individually so the the beetle actually
has no control over what it's doing yeah
so you basically make it into a a robot
actually
look so they're making it distinguishing
symptoms uh-huh and you're hoping you're
talking a composer the kind of stuff
these stimulation signals oh yes i think
so but still it is nasty unbelievable
it's like this but it's still amazing
that [ __ ] is reverse ratatouille man
that's kind of tight i like it i like
reverse rescue i like their reasoning
for it they were like uh use these
insects to help people that are crushed
under rubble yeah so that was that's
well maybe that's the um
angle that's the blanket the narrative
right but yes uh in essence but in the
future they're gonna use that to control
us obviously obviously
and just spy on us they're definitely
talking about like you know earthquakes
accidents uh you know any type of rubble
that uh makes it so that a human or a
dog or anything like that can't like
search for humans these uh cockroaches
are fitted with these robots that not
only make it so that they become
controlled in that way where you can
turn them off and on and move them this
way turn them off
like they you can you can press the
button so they stop moving whoa they're
still there but like
you can see it in the video where it's
like they have tension in their in their
legs or like they no longer can move or
they're they're going in walking too do
they make it touch this little dick
i'm just having to go like that the
whole time let me uh ask uh
let me ask jeeves real quick
can't move by itself at all anymore even
if they're not i think it can still move
by itself um toggle it yeah because he
was the second you turn it on yeah push
against like the stuff but so with these
cockroaches wait until they do like a
dance troupe like ken just oh my god
cockroach kenjos right and then you just
couldn't continue just did not know
cockroaches and kindles were gonna
cockroach canyons dude and then they'll
be like the cockroach walkies would be
much better oh
that's true if you don't know which
cockroach is which no no they're going
to be like the america's best cockroach
right and then they're going to have a
dance battle you know i like the kids or
cockroaches better actually oh really
yeah i think they're better than just
cockroaches so these magic king
corroches
are made to be autonomous agents for
searching through rubble for signs of
life they're six centimeters long uh and
they are pretty much equipped with a
type of computer that reads elevated co2
levels uh they they search for movement
they check body heat uh and the ai on
top of it decides whether or not there
is a presence of a person that is
detected which will alert the rescuer
that is controlling the backpack yeah
and how long until targeted
assassinations three weeks that's what i
said like it's cool but i also don't
like this assassin why
that's just kind of scary it's a
cockroach i know but that doesn't mean
that that's where they're gonna stop
they won't stop they never stop they
never you don't you don't want to see
little cockawackies
what i don't want to see is like a wonky
[ __ ] okay they have the better name
they got the better name that's a good
name king corroaches
that's way better dude
um
so this is like that moment this is like
that moment in uh terminator 2 judgment
day right where they got to go back
right yeah search for the dude who first
invents the chip because that chip
wasn't necessarily created for skynet at
that time to turn into a killing machine
they first wanted to just yeah like i
don't know make internet accessible for
everybody via a satellite right so
you're saying that this is that moment
this is that pre-skydiving moment
where if we unlock this tech it's really
just going to turn into an ai robot
killing machine that's going to
eliminate humanity for the sake of
humanity then they're going to put it
like on gorillas and bears and
[ __ ] once they put on bears is over dude
yeah we're getting [ __ ] over they
don't got i don't know for bears
can swim oh [ __ ] they put it on raccoons
or they put on like mosquitoes with
malaria exactly
make sure they're the malaria ones
the good ones because the mosquitoes can
hold these backpacks
just go to las vegas mosquitoes can't go
there i like that
i haven't been bit since i've lived
there it's [ __ ] lit that's probably
that's a really big upside it's a huge
there's no mosquitoes no really
have you heard of the um uh the thing
where obviously uh elon musk is working
on neurolink and stuff like that right
he's obviously putting [ __ ] actual
chips ai coordinating things and like
monkey breaks which is pretty cool he's
obviously supposed to move to human
trials and all that stuff but he talks
about um
what is what is that like the uh the
tipping point the singularity he talks
about the moment of singularity right
where ai catches up to the point and is
able to uh you know think better more
intelligently or faster or react to the
human species and recognize that that
we're [ __ ] up the world therefore
if it was in their code to protect the
planet or life in general they might
start killing so there's another
singularity that's supposed to happen
and he believes that that's going to
happen
so he says instead of fighting that
because it's gonna happen anyway we need
to embrace it and become a more cyborg
mixture versus fighting humans versus
a.i
become the same joe do you remember like
four years ago when we went to that um
crypto mansion
and all these cats there were like me
and joe were just like you know we're
trying to [ __ ] get rich off of crypto
and these cats are sitting there and
they're like they're like
right now it's all about one thing
preparing for the singularity and like
they're talking about how like in the
next decade everything that they're
trying to do like to line up all their
crypto moves is to make sure that
they're prepared for the singularity 30
years ahead and they're all like rh our
age yeah we met some guys there that was
already doing the stem sale like uh
banking [ __ ] like where he's like yeah
what we do is you know we just save
everyone's stem cells and then we just
uh have it in our bank and he goes when
the technology catches up you're gonna
want your own stem cells from when
you're in your 20s you don't want to get
it when you're 50 and i'm like how much
is this process and i was thinking about
it and i was like
[ __ ] it
how much was it there's only a couple
grand to get it started and then like
every year it's like a fee
yeah but you can do that now too like
when you but when you get like a baby
and [ __ ] they save the [ __ ] placenta
or whatever that's good but meanwhile
these guys they're all like sitting
there like going around the table about
their goals and [ __ ] and it comes to me
and joe and it's like oh we're just
trying to turn like a small amount of
money into like a big amount of money
yeah they're all like time
what about the singularity what are you
guys preparing i don't even know what it
is
the founder of the myetherwallet uh
website at the time it was um my crypto
you know how'd you guys hang out with
these guys uh one of my friends who
got in really early in bitcoin started
creating like a special exclusive uh
like what do you call it like a podcast
right where where he would bring in
guests and stuff and and then it was
like the top people of crypto at the
time because he was like how do we
filter through all this [ __ ] because
right now if you go on youtube right you
have a lot of crypto youtubers who
aren't actually rich who got into the
whole thing
after like 2018 um but then he was like
this was back in 2017 and then he's all
like bringing in people who started this
[ __ ] like in the very beginning and who
are at the top and he wanted to create
like a podcast of that and it was like
500 bucks a month just to listen to this
podcast and so he's like what are we
gonna do with all this [ __ ] money
because there's all these like rich
people that are early adopters and he
goes you know what let's have fun
and book out mansions
like every every three four months
they'll be in europe asia america
whatever and then he's like and let's
just invite people to chill and talk and
then we'll get all these notes and then
we'll do these podcasts and whatever so
he was just like hey you want to come to
one of our dinners and i'm like [ __ ]
yeah and then i was like yo steve crypto
steve we gotta go and then we're just
sitting there [ __ ] eating some
chipotle or something yeah like catering
definitely catering although you guys
got pulled into a mansion talking about
the singularity and stem cells
it was funny though it was like some
kind of like food like that
[ __ ] table full of geniuses and you
know when they come over to me i'm like
what are you doing i'm starting a
restaurant with my friends and i do
youtube comedy and i like to invest and
i'm like i'm like bang bus pranks bro
sorry so let's let's i'm trying to take
a small amount of money
and we're talking about like people in
the room who are all like eight figure
nine figure like big [ __ ] right
and they're really smart too so half of
the [ __ ] they're saying was like i feel
like i'm in the [ __ ] lab and i'm the
rack
they're so beyond the money part of it
and that's the only part that me and joe
are interested in
so we're like there to get like all
kinds of cool nugs about like all this
all the industry and [ __ ] and they're
all just talking about singularity [ __ ]
and we enjoy looking just like we're
trying to get a [ __ ] little little
nugget of something give us some [ __ ]
what coin should i buy tech dudes at the
highest level like
they [ __ ] don't care about them no
dude maybe it's just a front it's like
one of those things where it's like
that's the society it's like really you
just want the money but once you're
there you're like yeah singularity that
is the or that's the justifiable baby i
swear if you were there you would
understand because it's like they're all
just talking their own like they're all
like this highfalutin [ __ ] like
futuristic people and me and joe are
just like regular joes like like oopsie
daisies we like should we be working
here
should i get you coffee or something
yeah yeah it was fun though it was
really fun
yeah it was pretty cool but then it just
gave me an inside look to like how
technology is made it's like those guys
seem like ai's already yeah that's so
funny if they just they just see things
differently and then they're they're
they're like
you're all are we eating chipotle and
they're like look again
[Laughter]
caviar [ __ ] matrix
[Laughter]
you're doing it
you're doing it steve you're seeing
beyond the money
there is this one dude i forgot his
youtube channel but he he's famous for
doing these like intimate interviews
it's all in black and white
of uh like hookers oh wow white white
underbelly
yes yes
so he has this one
i love that guy he has this one guy on
there it's like he's it's his black hat
hacker right oh that's a great really
good one right so there's a there's a
two part to it the second party comes
back and he says he has over seven
billion dollars in bitcoin but he still
enjoys his nine-to-five job because his
passion is literally hacking all day
long
and he doesn't
he goes even if he's like i don't know
what i'm gonna do with this you know but
then he bought bitcoin so [ __ ] early
and he just
early adopter he's in that techno tech
world right and he goes yeah i have
seven billion dollars in bitcoin um
and then he's like but i can't you know
he goes i've been this is my passion
like i've been hacking since i was a
child because i don't know what else to
do this dude's episode's amazing yeah
and he's a good like catch myself like
on that youtube thing just like watching
so many different the appalachian ones
it's crazy that's a really good uh
and it's cool because that guy like you
know he shoots all these crackheads and
all these like addicts and hookers and
then people are like why don't you just
give them money and he's like dude if
you [ __ ] really know these people
like that's the last thing you want to
do but he does help some of them out
i've seen and then like there was one
where he brought this one prostitute on
three times because like he helped her
out and then he found out that like at
the end all the money she kept asking
him for like crazy amounts of money but
then she was just giving it to her pimp
and her pimp and him and her on the show
and stuff i was like that [ __ ] crazy
it's like a 3 a.m too i'm gonna stay
enough watching it i'm like [ __ ]
you're like i need to know about this
champion prostitute now yeah
[Music]